ATLANTA.
DAVID WESTIN IS WITH BILL
CLINTON.
DAVID: I WANT TO SPEND A MINUTE
ON ORLANDO.
I WILL BE PERSONAL WITH THIS.
WHEN I WAS RUNNING ABC NEWS, YOU
DID A LIVE PROGRAM WITH YOUR
WIFE AFTER COLUMBINE.
I REMEMBER HOW EMOTIONAL THAT
WAS.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN THAT JOB WHEN
THERE HAS BEEN TRAGEDY, HUGE
TRAGEDY.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO AVOID THIS?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: WE NEED MORE
HELP WITH INTELLIGENCE WORK WITH
FEDERAL AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH PEOPLE MIGHT BE
LONE WOLVES.
LIKE THE PEOPLE IN SAN
BERNARDINO, THEY WERE CONVERTED
OVER THE INTERNET.
TODAY WE STILL DON'T KNOW ALL OF
WHAT WE WILL EVENTUALLY LEARN
ABOUT THE MAN WHO KILLED ALL
THOSE PEOPLE IN ORLANDO.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF CRAZY
THEORIES FLOATING AROUND.
IT DOES SEEM CLEAR THAT SOME
PEOPLE WERE IN TOUCH WITH HIM,
PERHAPS EVEN IN HIS OWN FAMILY,
NEW HE WAS GOING TO BE DOING
SOMETHING.
WE'VE GOT TO GET BETTER AT THAT.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
IT'S ALSO TRUE IN OTHER AREAS.
THERE ARE CLEAR SIGNS OF
SUICIDES.
THIS IS SOMETHING NEW.
YOU CAN GO DOWN TO YOUR STORE
AND GET AN AR-15 AND WIPE OUT A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE.
WE NEED TIGHTER SECURITY ON
THAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT HILLARY
SAID IN HER SPEECH ARE ACCURATE
TO THE OTHER THINGS WE CAN DO TO
TIGHTEN OUR AND -- DEFENSES AT
HOME.
I KEPT THINKING OVER AND OVER
THE MORE I HEAR ABOUT THIS, I
WAS GLAD TO HEAR THE FBI
DIRECTOR SAY HE WAS ASKING
HIMSELF IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE
HE SHOULD OF DONE?
THAT'S WHAT EVERY AMERICAN
SHOULD ASK.
WE'VE GOT TO BE ON A HIGHER
ALERT.
WE CAN'T IGNORE SOMEONE YOU
THINK YOU -- IS RANTING AND
RAVING.
DAVID: YESTERDAY THE TWO
CANDIDATES SAID TWO THINGS.
WE SHOULD EXCLUDE PEOPLE FROM
MUSLIM COUNTRIES FROM COMING
HERE.
SOME OF THEM HAVE THIS IDEOLOGY.
IF WE HAD MORE PEOPLE WITH GUNS
AND THAT NIGHT CLUB, THERE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN THIS TRAGEDY.
PRESIDENT CLINTON: DID YOU SEE
HOW DARK IT WAS?
I THINK IT'S LIKELY MORE PEOPLE
WOULD'VE BEEN KILLED.
ALL I KNOW IS THIS: WE HAD A 10
YEAR BAN ON ASSAULT WEAPONS.
THAT HAS PASSED WHEN I WAS
PRESIDENT AND I SIGNED IT AND WE
PUT OUR OR IT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS LOST THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE THEY VOTED FOR THAT
, IT WAS A COMPREHENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECK LAW.
WE HAD A 33 YEAR LOW IN THE GUN
DEATH RATE AND A 46 LOW BY GUN
HOMICIDES.
IT WORKED PRETTY WELL.
WHEN IT WAS ALLOWED TO EXPIRE,
FOR A WHILE WE DIDN'T SEEM TO
HAVE AN UPTICK IN CRIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THESE BIG WEAPONS AT SANDY
HOOK AND AURORA, COLORADO AND
MOST RECENTLY IN ORLANDO AND SAN
BERNARDINO, IT'S CLEAR THAT IF
YOU ARE FIRING A LOT OF
AMMUNITION IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME, WITH A WEAPON THAT IS
DESIGNED ONLY TO KILL, IF THE
GUY JUST HAD A PISTOL IN THAT
NIGHT CLUB, I DON'T THINK HE
COULD'VE KILLED 49 PEOPLE.
THAT'S MY RESPONSE.
DAVID: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE CGI
AMERICAN INITIATIVE.
I WANT TO BE SPECIFIC.
THERE IS ONE INITIATIVE THAT
CAME OUT OF THE MEETINGS LAST
YEAR HERE.
I AM FROM MICHIGAN.
I WAS JUST BACK TO DETROIT
VISITING.
TAKE US THROUGH THAT INITIATIVE.
HOW DID IT WORK?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: DETROIT WAS
COMING OUT OF BANKRUPTCY.
THERE WAS A VIGOROUS NEW MAYOR.
HE REALLY WANTED TO HELP PEOPLE
MOVE DOWNTOWN IN A HURRY.
WHEN HE BECAME MAYOR, HE WAS IN
CONTROL OF 50% OF THE LAND MASS
IN DOWNTOWN DETROIT.
SOME OF THE PROPERTY NEEDED TO
BE CLEARED BECAUSE THEY COULD
USE MORE GREEN SPACE.
IT DID NOT SEEM LIKE ANYBODY
WOULD COME BACK TO LIVE THERE.
THERE WERE 10,000 STRUCTURALLY
SOUND CAPITAL STRUCTURES --
HABITABLE STRUCTURES.
PEOPLE WANTED TO HELP DETROIT
COME BACK.
THEY ALL NEEDED REPAIRS.
THE BANKS HAD THE VALUE OF THE
HOME BASED ONLY ON THE
STRUCTURE.
SOME OF THEM ARE QUITE
MAGNIFICENT.
THEY WERE IN NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
OTHER HOUSES WERE FAKE IT.
THE PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO MOVE
DOWNTOWN AFFORD TO BUY THE HOME
AND REPAIR IT.
THEY NEEDED MORE MORTGAGE HELP
THAN WHAT A BANK COULD LEGALLY
GIVE THEM ON A FIRST MORTGAGE.
THE MAYOR TALKED ABOUT IT.
I HAVE A REAL INTEREST IN
DETROIT AND WANTED TO HELP.
SOME WERE FROM OUT OF TOWN.
THEY JUST PUT THEIR HEADS
TOGETHER FOR THREE DAYS AND THEY
CAME UP WITH THE SITE VIA OF HOW
A SECOND MORTGAGE COULD BE
ISSUED THAT WOULD ENABLE THE
HOMEOWNER TO MAKE THE HOME
HABITABLE AND THE REPAYMENT
COULD BE STRUCTURED IN A WAY
THAT WOULD NOT CRIPPLE THEM
FINANCIALLY.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
IT PUT 1000 PEOPLE MORE IN
HOMES.
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF SOMETHING
THAT WILL HAVE APPLICATIONS IN
OTHER DISTRESSED AREAS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I HOPE SO.
DAVID: WHAT WAS IT THAT HAD
FAILED?
IT WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT THE CGI AMERICA.
WELL-MEANING PEOPLE COULD NOT
HAVE GOTTEN TOGETHER.
WHAT WAS THE FAILURE IN THAT?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: IT'S NOT SO
MUCH THE FAILURE.
IT'S DIFFICULT IN A COMPLEX
SOCIETY TO SET UP A SYSTEM THAT
LOOKS AT EVERY POTENTIAL
PROBLEM.
IF WE HAD NOT HAD THE FINANCIAL
CRASH, THESE BANKS THAT THERE
WAS ENOUGH SLACK FROM REGULATORS
TO DO SOMETHING THEY CLEARLY
SHOULD NOT HAVE DONE.
NOW THEY COULD DO IT.
WE FIGURED OUT HOW TO CLOSE A
GAP IN THE FABRIC OF OUR HOUSING
MARKET.
THAT IS REALLY WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO DO WHEN I STARTED MY
FOUNDATION 15 YEARS AGO.
I WANTED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS AT LOWER COST
THAN THEY WOULD OTHERWISE BE
SOLVED.
I SAW THIS A LOT.
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PASSING LAW
AND CHANGING LIVES.
THERE IS A GREAT VILLA OF
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN APPROPRIATING
MONEY AND CHANGING LIVES.
I THINK THE MORE COMPLEX AND
INTERDEPENDENT ARE SOCIETY GETS,
THE MORE PREMIUM WE PUT ON
PEOPLE WHO CAN ANSWER THE HOW
QUESTION.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WITH DIVERSE
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE.
IF THEY WANT TO GET A JOB DONE,
IF THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT WHAT
THE POLITICS ARE AND THEY'RE
JUST TRYING TO GET A JOB DONE,
YOU FIND A WAY TO DO IT FASTER
AND AT LOWER COST.
DAVID: YOU HAVE A BODY OF WORK
NOW.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED OVER THOSE
YEARS?
WHAT CAN BE ADDRESSED AND SOLVED
BY THIS SORT OF COOPERATIVE
EFFORT?
WHICH DON'T FIT SO WELL?
RESIDENT BUTTON: -- PRESIDENT
CLINTON: LET'S START WITH THE
SECOND CATEGORY.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
REQUIRE A THRESHOLD LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR OR GOVERNMENT.
WITHOUT THAT, YOU CAN'T DO IT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
YOU ARE FROM FLINT.
FLINT IS NOT THE ONLY CITY IN
THE COUNTRY WHERE CHILDREN HAVE
ELEVATED LEVELS OF LEAD IN THEIR
BLOOD.
WE HAVE DONE WHAT WE COULD TO
HELP FLINT.
IT WOULD TAKE A NATIONAL
COMMITMENT TO SERIOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO TAKE OUT ALL
THE RUSTY PIPES IN AMERICA AND
GIVE THE KIDS A HEALTHY FUTURE.
IT WOULD BE A VERY GOOD
INVESTMENT AND CREATE A LOT OF
JOBS.
THERE WOULD STILL BE PROBLEMS IN
PARTICULAR PLACES.
THAT'S A THRESHOLD THING.
WE CAN NOW BECAUSE SOLAR AND
WIND POWER ARE CHEAP THAN THEY
WERE -- CHEAPER THAN THEY WERE,
WE CAN PUT TOGETHER A COALITION
TO ACCELERATE THE INCOME
BENEFITS IN THE CLIMATE AND FITS
OF SOLAR AND WIND POWER --
BENEFITS OF SOLAR AND WIND
POWER.
IF, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU WANT TO
HELP THE POOREST AMERICANS
LIVING ON INDIAN LAND WITHOUT
CASINOS, A LOT OF THEM COULD BE
MAKING A FORTUNE OUT OF THIS.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE
TRANSMISSION LINES TO CARRY THE
POWER TO ANY PLACE THAT CAN
RECEIVE IT.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS YOU CAN'T
DO.
THE THINGS YOU CAN DO INVOLVE
GETTING PEOPLE TO RETHINK WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
YOU CAN SEE IF THEY CAN BE
FAITHFUL TO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH THEIR
ASSETS AND DO IT IN A WAY WITH
MORE SOCIAL BENEFIT.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
THIS IS ONE QUICK ONE.
I WAS HAVING A CONVERSATION FIVE
YEARS AGO WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE AFL-CIO.
LABOR IS UNDER A LOT OF STRESS.
I THINK HE SHOULD CONSIDER
TAKING YOUR WELL-FUNDED PENSION
FUND AND INVESTING MONEY IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS,
ESPECIALLY IN YOUR -- ENERGY
RETROFITS.
THAT WOULD A LOT OF UNION
WORKERS TO WORK IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
IT WOULD HELP THE PENSION FUND
IT.
HE JUST CHEWED ON IT AND GOT ME
IN TOUCH WITH SOME PEOPLE.
WE GOT $10 BILLION IN
COMMITMENTS.
NOW THE COMMITMENT IS $14
BILLION.
THAT HAS BEEN ALLOCATED.
SOME OF IT HAS BEEN SPENT AND
100,000 JOBS A BEEN CREATED
DOING THESE BUILDING RETROFIT
PROJECTS.
IT CREATED A LOT OF JOBS.
IT'S DONE A WORLD OF GOOD.
THE PENSION FUNDS HAVE BEEN
RETURNED.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING I DO.
HOW CAN YOU DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENTLY?
COCA-COLA IS ONE OF THE HOSTS OF
THIS CGI AMERICA.
THEY JOINED WITH PEPSICO.
DAVID: HOW ABOUT THAT?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: THEY AGREED
TO CHANGE WHAT THEY WERE PUTTING
IN THE DRINKS GOING TO CHILDREN
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WITH VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS, THEY
REDUCED THE CALORIES GOING TO
KIDS IN SCHOOL BY 90%.
THAT'S THE STUFF I TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO DO.
DAVID: GIVEN THAT TRACK RECORD,
LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT YOU
EXPECT AND HOPE WILL HAPPEN NEXT
NOVEMBER, WHAT HAPPENS TO YOUR
INITIATIVE IF YOUR WIFE IS
PRESIDENT?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: I WANT TO SAY
WHAT SHE DID.
IF SHE WINS, WE WILL HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
THERE ARE CLEARLY THINGS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT.
I JUST TRY TO GET PARTNERS
TOGETHER AND MAKE SOMETHING GOOD
HAPPEN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TRIED TO
INVOLVE MORE PEOPLE FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND A LOT OF HIS
DECISION-MAKING.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL TO AVOID
ACTUAL POTENTIAL CONFLICTS.
DAVID: DONALD TRUMP HAS RAISED
THAT.
IT GETS DICIER.
PRESIDENT CLINTON: WE WILL THINK
VERY CLEARLY ABOUT IT AND WE
WILL DO THE RIGHT THING.
WE WILL EXPLAIN IT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WILL HAVE TO WAIT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN CHICKENS --
COUNTING YOUR CHICKENS BEFORE
THEY HATCH.
WE WILL SEE HOW THE ELECTION
UNFOLDS.
THERE WILL CLEARLY BE SOME
CHANGES AND WHAT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION DOESN'T HOW WE DO IT.
WE WILL HAVE TO CROSS THAT
BRIDGE WHEN WE COME TO IT.
DAVID: YOU SERVED AS PRESIDENT
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
THERE WAS SOME HEATED RHETORIC
BACK-AND-FORTH AND UP AND DOWN.
WHAT WE SEE IN THIS ELECTION
STRIKES ME OF HAVING A LEVEL OF
PERSONAL ATTACK.
IT'S NOT UNIQUELY ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME CANDIDATES
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE AS WELL.
IS THIS A PERMANENT CHANGE IN
THE POLITICAL DISCOURSE IN THIS
COUNTRY?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S EASIER TO SAY THINGS THAT
DON'T MAKE A LICK OF SENSE NOW.
SO MANY OF OUR PEOPLE ARE SILENT
IN THEIR INFORMATION.
I TELL PEOPLE ALL THE TIME, WE
ARE LESS SEXIST, RACIST, AND
HOME -- HOMOPHOBIC THAN WE USED
TO BE.
OUR BIGOTRY IS WE DON'T WANT TO
BE AROUND 70 DISAGREES WITH US.
-- SOMEONE WHO DISAGREES WITH
US.
IF YOU'RE IN THAT SILO, YOU
BELIEVE ANYTHING YOUR PREJUDICE
WILL ALLOW.
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR US.
ONE OF THE REASONS I LIKE THESE
EVENTS IS BECAUSE PEOPLE HERE
COME FROM THERE HE POLITICAL
PERSPECTIVES.
THEY MAKE A LIVING DIFFERENT
WAYS.
THEY FIND IT STIMULATING TO BE
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE DIFFERENT.
THEY FIND THAT WHAT WE KNOW IS
DIVERSE GROUPS MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS THAN LOAN GENIUSES.
MUCH LESS A GROUP OF TOTALLY
LIKE THINKING PEOPLE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE SENSITIVE
TO THAT.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
BREAK OUT OF OUR SILOS.
FUNDAMENTALLY, PEOPLE ARE
DECENT.
A LOT OF THESE CAMPAIGNS HAVE
GOTTEN HARSHER AND HARSHER
BECAUSE OF THE LONG DRAG AFTER
THE CRASH.
IN MANY PLACES, THERE IS A
COMBINATION OF STAGNANT INCOMES
AND DISRUPTIVE THREATS TO
IDENTITY.
EUROPE HAS THE BIGGEST REFUGEE
CRISIS SINCE WORLD WAR II.
YOU HAD A CONTEST AND AUSTRIA.
IT'S A CLOSE CONTEST.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
THINK THEY CAN MAKE THEIR
TOMORROW'S -- CAN'T MAKE THEIR
TOMORROW'S BETTER.
THEY FEEL CONSCIOUSLY OR
SUBCONSCIOUSLY THAT THE WORLD
DISRESPECTS OR DISREGARDS THEM
OR DOESN'T SEE THEM.
THEY ARE LESS OFFENDED IF
SOMEBODY ELSE IS IN THE
TREATMENT.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO BE A LOT
MORE SENSITIVE.
WE NEED TO BE MORE SENSITIVE TO
WHAT OUR NEIGHBORS ARE GOING
THROUGH.
I THINK IF WE DID THAT, WE WOULD
CHANGE THE CULTURE BACK TO WHERE
OUR POLITICS IS MORE HUMANE.
DAVID: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
GROWING THE ECONOMY.
IT STRIKES ME THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS INJECTED THIS TIME IS
QUESTIONING THE QUALIFICATIONS
TO SERVE.
IT'S ONE THING TO DISAGREE, IT'S
ONE THING TO SAY I WOULD BE
BETTER, IT'S DIFFERENT TO SAY
YOU SHOULDN'T BE CONSIDERED FOR
THE OFFICE.
WHAT SHOULD BE THE
QUALIFICATIONS WE ARE LOOKING
FOR?
PRESIDENT CLINTON: THAT'S A
DECISION THE VOTERS MAKE EVERY
ELECTION.
I WAS WELL-SUITED TO BE
PRESIDENT WHEN I WAS ELECTED
BECAUSE I WAS A GOVERNOR AND MY
STATE HAD A FAST-GROWING ECONOMY
AND A BIG IMPROVEMENT IN THE
THINGS AMERICA NEEDED TO IMPROVE
ON.
BECAUSE I KNEW WHAT PEOPLE WERE
UP AGAINST.
AT A MINIMUM, YOU WANT SOMEBODY
WHO BELIEVES THAT WE ARE NOT
JUST A PLACE WHERE --, WE ARE AN
IDEA.
WE ARE BORN TO WELCOME PEOPLE
FROM EVERY PLACE WHO LOVE
FREEDOM AND BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW AND RESPECT OTHER
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS.
SOMEONE WITH A PROVEN RECORD OF
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
WE DO HAVE OTHER RULES THAT
DEVELOP OVER TIME.
THE VOTERS DECIDE THAT.
THEY DECIDE WHO IS QUALIFIED.
I THINK MY JOB IS TO SUPPORT ONE
PARTICULAR CANDIDATE WHO I THINK
IS THE MOST QUALIFIED PERSON IN
AMERICA TO SERVE AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME.
WE NEED SOMEONE WHO UNDERSTANDS
HOW THE GOVERNMENT CAN ADD SOME
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND CAN MAKE
PROSPERITY MORE WIDELY SHARED TO
REDUCE INEQUALITY AND INCREASE
UPWARD MOBILITY.
THEY CAN BREAK POLITICAL
GRIDLOCK IN WASHINGTON.
OUR ECONOMIC FATE IS TIED UP
WITH WHAT HAPPENS IN THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
IN THE LAST ECONOMIC REPORT
THERE WAS A PIECE OF GOOD NEWS.
MORE THAN $.61 OF A DOLLAR ON
CORPORATE DOLLARS WENT TO WAGES.
A PIECE OF BAD NEWS WAS IN SPITE
OF HIRING, GROWTH HAD DROPPED
BACK DUE ENTIRELY TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING AROUND THE WORLD.
BRAZIL, CHINA SLOWING DOWN,
SOUTHEAST ASIA, ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON.
IT'S NOT AN EASY JOB RIGHT NOW.
IT'S A DOABLE ONE.
IT'S NOT DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
DAVID: --
MARK: WE ARE INTERRUPTING OUR
CONVERSATION WITH BILL CLINTON.
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS SET TO SPEAK
ON TERRORISM.
HE IS AT THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS
STORY TODAY.
GIVEN THE EVENTS IN ORLANDO AND
WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT OUTSIDE
PARIS, A MAN WHO HAD ALLEGIANCE
TO ISLAMIC STATE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE DEATH OF A POLICE
OFFICIAL AND HIS WIFE.
WHAT CAN THE PRESIDENT SAY TODAY
THAT WILL ALLAY PEOPLE'S FEARS?
ANGELA: HE IS MEETING WITH HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM.
THIS MEETING WAS PREVIOUSLY
SCHEDULED.
THE TENOR OF THE MEETING HAS
TAKEN A DIFFERENT TONE.
WHAT WE EXPECT TO HEAR THE
PRESIDENT SAY IS HE IS DOING
EVERYTHING HE CAN TO BE AWARE
AND TRACKING A POTENTIAL ATTACK,
LONE WOLVES LIKE WE SAW IN
ORLANDO.
HE WILL CALL FOR HIS GUN CONTROL
TO BE IN -- ENACTED.
HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
MEASURES AS PART OF HIS LEGACY.
HE IS NOT GIVING UP ON WAYS TO
MAKE SOME OF THOSE CHANGES.
MARK: YOU TALK ABOUT THE LONE
WOLF ATTACKS, CONGRESS HAS SAID
THIS IS THE THING THAT GIVES
THEM PAUSE, THE THING THAT KEEPS
THEM AWAKE AND NIGHT.
IF ONE HAS NOT PLEDGED
ALLEGIANCE, THEY MAY BECOME SELF
RADICALIZED.
ARE THERE STEPS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO PREVENT OR IDENTIFY
THIS PROBLEM #ANGELA: THAT'S
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
HE HAS ADVISERS HE IS MEETING
WITH.
>> IS EVERYBODY ALL SET?
PRESIDENT OBAMA: I JUST MET WITH
MY SECURITY TEAM.
OUR MEETING WAS PLANNED BEFORE
THE TERRIBLE ATTACK IN ORLANDO.
THAT TRAGEDY, THE AWFUL LOSS OF
LIFE, SHAPED MUCH OF OUR WORK
TODAY.
IN ALL OF OUR EFFORTS, FOREMOST
IN OUR MINDS IS THE LOSS AND THE
GRIEF OF THE PEOPLE OF ORLANDO
PEOPLE -- ORLANDO.
FAMILIES OF SEEING LOVED ONES
HARMED, THE FRIENDS OF OURS WHO
ARE LESBIAN AND GAY AND BISEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER WHO WERE
TARGETED.
I WANT TO REMIND THEM THAT THEY
ARE NOT ALONE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND OUR
ALLIES AND FRIENDS ALL OVER THE
WORLD STAND WITH YOU.
THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT YOU AND
PRAYING FOR YOU.
AS DIRECTOR KOMI HAS SAID -- FBI
DIRECTOR KOMI HAS SAID, WE HAVE
NO INTELLIGENCE THAT A FOREIGN
GROUP DIRECTED IT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE SHOOTER
TOOK IN INFORMATION OVER THE
INTERNET.
HE APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN AN
ANGRY, DISTURBED, UNSTABLE YOUNG
MAN WHO BECAME RADICALIZED.
TERRORIST GROUPS HAVE CALLED ON
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD TO
ATTACK INNOCENT CIVILIANS.
THOSE POSTINGS ARE PERVASIVE.
THEY ARE MORE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
THAN WE WANT.
THIS INDIVIDUAL APPEARS TO HAVE
ABSORBED SOME OF THAT.
THE SHOOTER IN ORLANDO PLEDGED
ALLEGIANCE TO ISIL.
THESE LONE ACTORS ARE VERY HARD
TO DETECT AND VERY HARD TO
PREVENT.
ACROSS OUR GOVERNMENT, WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING IN HER POWER TO
STOP THESE KINDS OF ATTACKS.
WE WORK TO SUCCEED 100% OF THE
TIME.
AN ATTACKER ONLY HAS TO SUCCEED
ONCE.
OUR PERSONNEL AND OUR
INTELLIGENCE AND A MILITARY AND
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE
PREVENTED MANY ATTACKS AND SAVED
MANY LIVES.
WE CAN NEVER THANK THEM ENOUGH.
WE ARE ALL SOBERED BY THE FACT
THAT DESPITE THE EXTRAORDINARY
HARD WORK, SOMETHING LIKE
ORLANDO CAN OCCUR.
THE DEI DIRECTOR IN -- UPDATED
US.
-- THE FBI DIRECTOR UPDATED US.
SECRETARY CARTER REVIEWED THE
MILITARY CAMPAIGN AGAINST ISIS.
I WANT TO THANK TREASURY FOR
HOSTING US.
WE APPRECIATE THEIR EFFORTS TO
CUT OFF THE MONEY THAT FUNDS
ISIS.
I WANT TO REITERATE OUR
OBJECTIVE.
OUR MISSION IS TO DESTROY ISIS.
WE'VE SEEN THE DIFFICULT FIGHT.
WE ARE MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
I HAVE AUTHORIZED STEPS TO
RATCHET UP OUR FIGHT AGAINST
ISIS.
SPECIAL FORCES ARE IN SYRIA.
ADDITIONAL ADVISERS ARE WORKING
WITH THE IRAQI SECURITY FORCES.
ADDITIONAL ASSETS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED.
OUR AIRCRAFT CONTINUED TO LAUNCH
FROM THE USS HARRY TRUMAN NOW IN
THE MEDITERRANEAN.
OUR B-52 BOMBERS ARE HITTING
ISIL WITH PRECISION STRIKES.
TARGETS ARE BEING IDENTIFIED AND
HIT EVEN MORE QUICKLY.
13,000 AIRSTRIKES OF BEEN
CARRIED OUT SO FAR.
WE ARE FIRING ON ALL CYLINDERS.
ISIL IS UNDER MORE PRESSURE THAN
EVER BEFORE.
THEY LOSE KEY LEADERS.
THIS INCLUDES THE SENIOR
MILITARY LEADER IN MOZ OH.
-- MOZ OH.
SO FAR, WE'VE TAKEN OUT 120 TOP
ISIL LEADERS AND COMMANDERS.
OUR MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
IF YOU TARGET AMERICA, YOU WILL
NOT BE SAFE.
YOU WILL NEVER BE SAFE.
ISIL CONTINUES TO LOSE GROUND IN
IRAQ.
IN THE PAST TWO MONTHS, LOCAL
FORCES HAVE LIBERATED A WESTERN
TOWN AND PUSHED UP THE EUPHRATES
RIVER VALLEY.
THEY HAVE BREAK IN THE SIEGE.
-- BROKEN THE SIEGE.
THEY HAVE SURROUNDED FALLUJA AND
STARTED TO MOVE INTO THE CITY.
THEY PUSH UP THE TIGRIS RIVER
VALLEY.
THEY ARE PREPARING TO TIGHTEN
THE NOOSE IN MOZ OH.
THEY HAVE LOST HALF OF THE
TERRITORY IT ONCE CONTROLLED AND
IT WILL LOSE MORE.
ISIS LOSES GROUND IN SYRIA AS
WELL.
THE NEWS IS TIGHTENING AROUND
THEM AS WELL.
OUR COALITION IS ON OFFENSE.
IT HAS BEEN A FULL YEAR SINCE
THEY HAVE AS THEY CONTINUE TO
LOSE TERRITORY, IT LOSES THE
MONEY THAT IS ITS LIFEBLOOD.
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE CUT THE
REVENUE BY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PER MONTH.
WE HAVE DESTROYED THE STORAGE
SITES WHERE THEY KEEP THEIR
CASH.
THANKS TO THE GREAT WORK OF MANY
OTHERS HERE TODAY AND WORKING
WITH NATIONS AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AROUND THE WORLD,
THEY ARE CUT OFF FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
CUTTING OFF THEIR MONEY MAY NOT
BE AS DRAMATIC, IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AREA THEIR CASH
RESERVES ARE DOWN.
THEY HAVE HAD TO CUT SALARIES.
THEY ARE RELATING TO MORE
EXTORTION.
SOME OF THE LEADERS HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT STEALING CASH AND GOLD.
THEIR TRUE NATURE HAS BEEN
REVEALED.
THESE ARE NOT RELIGIOUS LEADERS.
THEY ARE THUGS AND THIEVES.
I WANT TO MENTION THAT IT IS
CRITICAL FOR OUR FRIENDS IN THE
SENATE TO CONFIRM I NOMINEE FOR
UNDERSECRETARY OF TERRORISM AND
FINANCIAL INTELLIGENCE.
ADAM HAS SERVED IN BOTH
ADMINISTRATIONS.
EVERYONE AGREES HE IS QUALIFIED.
HE HAS BEEN WORKING ON THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES FOR YEARS.
IT'S NOW BEEN IT MORE THAN A
YEAR SINCE I NOMINATED HIM.
HE STILL HAS NOT BEEN GIVEN A
VOTE.
THERE IS NO GOOD REASON FOR IT.
IT IS INEXCUSABLE.
IT'S TIME FOR THE SENATE TO DO
ITS JOB AND PUT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY FIRST AND HAVE A VOTE.
HE CAN HELP KEEP OUR COUNTRY
SAFE.
ICICLES RANKS ARE -- THEIR RANKS
ARE SHRINKING AS WELL.
MORALE IS SINKING.
AS ONE DEFECTOR SAID, THEY ARE
NOT BRINGING ISLAM TO THE WORLD
AND PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT.
THE FLOW OF FOREIGN FIGHTERS
INCLUDING FROM AMERICA HAS
PLUMMETED.
OUR INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY SAYS
THE RANKS HAS BEEN LOSE TO THE
LOWEST LEVELS IN MORE THAN 2.5
YEARS.
WE ARE ADDRESSING THE LARGER
FORCES THAT HAVE ALLOWED THE
TERRORIST TO GRAIN -- GAIN
TRACTION.
THIS MEANS HELPING IRAQIS
STABILIZE COMMUNITIES AND
PROMOTE SO THE ISIL CANNOT
RETURN.
THIS MEANS OUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR THE FRAGILE END OF
HOSTILITIES IN SYRIA.
THIS HAS NOT STOPPED ALL OR EVEN
MOST OF THE HARDSHIP ON THE
SYRIAN PEOPLE.
THE ASSIGNED REGIME HAS BEEN THE
PRINCIPAL CULPRIT.
ISIL AND ITS AFFILIATE IN SYRIA
CONTINUES TO TERRORIZE SYRIANS.
AS FRAGILE AND INCOMPLETE AS IT
IS, IT HAS SAVED LIVES AND IT
HAS ALLOWED THE DELIVERY OF SOME
LIFE-SAVING AID TO SYRIANS WHO
ARE IN DESPERATE NEED.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO AND THE
CIVIL WAR AND RESULT IN A
TRANSITION AWAY FROM A SOD.
ISIL IS LOSING GROUND IN LIBYA.
FORCES OF THE UNITY GOVERNMENT
ARE GOING AFTER ISIL IN A
STRONGHOLD.
IT WILL RESIST THE NEW LIBYAN
GOVERNMENT AS IT WORKS TO SECURE
ITS COUNTRY.
LASTLY, HERE AT HOME, IF WE
REALLY WANT TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROTECT AMERICANS
FROM HOME-GROWN EXTREMISTS, THE
KIND OF TRAGEDIES THAT OCCURRED
AT SAN BERNARDINO AND NOW HAVE
OCCURRED IN ORLANDO, THERE IS A
MEANINGFUL WAY TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO KILL
AMERICANS TO GET THEIR HANDS ON
WEAPONS OF WAR THAT LET THEM
KILL DOZENS OF INNOCENTS.
HE CANNOT PREVENT EVERY TRAGEDY.
WE KNOW THAT.
CONSISTENT WITH THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, THERE ARE STEPS THAT
COULD REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE AND
COULD REDUCE THE LEGALITY OF
SOMEBODY WHO INTENDS TO DO OTHER
PEOPLE HARM.
WE SHOULD GIVE ATF THE RESOURCES
PEOPLE WITH POSSIBLE TIES TO
TERRORISM WHO ARE NOT ALLOWED ON
THE PLANE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO BUY A GUN.
I'M TALKING ABOUT BEING TOUGH ON
TERRORISM.
ACTUALLY BE TOUGH.
MAKE IT HARDER TO GET WEAPONS
THAT KILL US.
OTHERWISE, JUST  DESPITE
EXTRAORDINARY EFORTS BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE MILITARY,
AND ALL THE SACRIFICES THAT
PEOPLE MAKE, THESE EVENTS WILL
KEEP ON HAPPENING.
THE WEAPONS ARE ONLY GOING TO
GET MORE POWERFUL.
LET ME MAKE A FINAL POINT.
FOR A WHILE NOW, THE MAIN
CONTRIBUTION FROM PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE I'LL IS TO
CRITICIZE THE ADMINISTRATION AND
ME FOR NOT USING THE PHRASE,
"RADICAL ISLAM," THAT IS THE
KEY, THEY TELL US.
WE CANNOT BEAT THEM UNLESS WE
CALL THEM RADICAL ISLAMIST.
WHEN EXACTLY -- WHAT EXACTLY
WOULD USING THIS LABEL
ACCOMPLISH OR CHANGE?
WOULD IT MAKE THEM LESS
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO KILL
AMERICANS?
WOULD IT BRING IN MORE ALLIES?
IS THERE A MILITARY STRATEGY
SERVED BY THIS?
THE ANSWER IS NONE OF THE ABOVE.
CALLING A THREAT BY DIFFERENT
NAME DOES NOT MAKE IT GO AWAY.
THIS IS A POLITICAL DISTRACTION.
SINCE BEFORE I WAS PRESIDENT, I
HAVE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT HOW -- I
HAVE CALLED ON MUSLIMS AROUND
THE WORLD TO REJECT THIS
INTERPRETATION OF ONE OF THE
WORLD'S GREAT RELIGIONS.
IT HAS NOT BEEN A MOMENT IN MY
7.5 YEARS AS PRESIDENT WHERE WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO PURSUE A
STRATEGY BECAUSE WE DID NOT USE
A LABEL, "RADICAL ISLAM."
NOT ONCE HAS AN ADVISOR SAID, IF
WE USE THAT PHRASE, WE WILL TURN
THIS ALL AROUND.
NOT ONCE.
IF SOMEONE SERIOUSLY THINKS THAT
WE DO NOT KNOW WHO WE ARE
FIGHTING, IF THERE'S ANYONE OUT
THERE WHO THINKS WE ARE CONFUSED
ABOUT WHO OUR ENEMIES ARE, THAT
WOULD COME AS A SURPRISE TO THE
THOUSANDS OF TERRORISTS WE HAVE
TAKEN OFF THE BATTLEFIELD.
IF THE IMPLICATION IS THAT THOSE
OF US UP HERE AND THE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
WORLD THAT ARE WORKING TO DEFEAT
ISIL ARE NOT TAKING THE FIGHT
SERIOUSLY, THAT WOULD COME AS A
SURPRISE TO THOSE WHO HAVE SPENT
THE LAST 7.5 YEARS DISMANTLING
THEM, INCLUDING THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN UNIFORM WHO PUT THEIR
LIFE AT RISK AND THE SPECIAL
FORCES THAT ARE NOW ON THE
GROUND IN IRAQ AND SYRIA.
THEY KNOW FULL WELL WHO THE
ENEMY IS.
SO DO THE INTELLIGENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO SPEND
COUNTLESS HOURS DISRUPTING PLOTS
AND PROTECTING ALL AMERICANS.
INCLUDING POLITICIANS WHO TWEET
AND APPEAR ON CABLE NEWS SHOWS.
THEY KNOW WHO THE NATURE OF THE
ENEMY IS.
THERE IS NO MAGIC TO THE PHRASE,
"RADICAL ISLAM," IT IS A
POLITICAL TALKING POINT, NOT A
STRATEGY.
THE REASON I AM CAREFUL ABOUT
THE WAY I DESCRIBED THIS THREAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS AND EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH ACTUALLY DEFEATING
EXTREMISM.
GROUPS LIKE ISIL AND AL QAEDA
WANT TO MAKE THIS A WAR
BETWEEN AMERICA AND ISLAM WERE
ISLAM AND THE WEST.
THEY WANT TO CLAIM THAT THEY ARE
THE TRUE LEADERS OF OVER A
BILLION MUSLIMS AROUND THE WORLD
WHO REJECT THE CRAZY NOTIONS.
THEY WANT US TO VALIDATE THEM BY
SAYING THAT THEY SPEAK FOR THOSE
BILLION PLUS PEOPLE.
THAT IS THEIR PROPAGANDA,
HEALTHY RECRUIT.
IF WE FALL INTO THE TRAP OF
PAINTING ALL MUSLIMS WITH A
BROAD BRUSH AND IMPLY THAT WE
ARE AT WAR WITH AN ENTIRE
RELIGION, THEN WE ARE DOING THE
TERRORIST WORK FOR THEM.
UP UNTIL THIS POINT, THIS
ARGUMENT ABOUT LABELS HAS MOSTLY
TO SPEND RHETORIC.
SADLY, WE HAVE ALL BECOME
ACCUSTOMED TO THAT KIND OF
PARTISANSHIP, EVEN WHEN IT
INVOLVES THE FIGHT AGAINST THESE
EXTREMIST GROUPS.
THAT KIND OF YAPPING HAS NOT
INVENTED FOLKS ACROSS GOVERNMENT
FROM DOING THEIR JOBS.
FROM SACRIFICING WORKING REALLY
HARD TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE WE ARE NOW SEEING HOW
DANGEROUS THIS MINDSET AND
THINKING CAN BE.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE WHERE
THIS RHETORIC AND LOOSE TALK AND
SLOPPINESS ABOUT WHO EXACTLY WE
ARE FIGHTING, WHERE THIS CAN
LEAD US.
WE NOW HAVE PROPOSALS FROM THE
PRESUMPTIVE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO BAR ALL MUSLIMS FROM
EMIGRATING TO AMERICA.
WE HEAR LANGUAGE THAT SINGLES
OUT IMMIGRANTS AND SUGGESTS
ANTI-RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES ARE
COMPLICIT IN VIOLENCE.
WHERE DOES THIS STOP?
DEAR LANDO KILLER, ONE OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO KILLERS, THE FT.
HOOD KILLER, THEY WERE ALL U.S.
CITIZENS.
ARE WE GOING TO TREAT ALL MUSLIM
AMERICANS DIFFERENTLY?
ARE WE GOING TO SUBJECT THEM TO
SURVEILLANCE?
ARE WE GOING TO DISCRIMINATE
THEM BECAUSE OF THEIR FAITH?
WE HAVE HEARD THE SUGGESTIONS
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
CAMPAIGN TO REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH US?
THAT IS NOT THE AMERICA WE WANT.
IT DOES NOT REFLECT OUR
DEMOCRATIC IDEALS.
IT WILL NOT MAKE US MORE SAFE.
IT WILL MAKE US LESS SAFE,
FEELING THE NOTION THAT THE WEST
HATES MUSLIMS, MAKING YOUNG
MUSLIMS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD FEEL LIKE NO
MATTER WHAT THEY DO, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE UNDER SUSPICION AND
ATTACK.
IT MAKES MUSLIM AMERICANS FEEL
LIKE THEIR GOVERNMENT IS THE
TRAIN THEM -- BETRAYING THEM.
IT BETRAYS THE VERY VALUES THAT
AMERICA STANDS FOR.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH MOMENTS IN
OUR HISTORY BEFORE WHEN WE ACTED
OUT OF FEAR, AND WE CAME TO
REGRET IT.
WE HAVE SEEN OUR GOVERNMENT
MISTREAT OUR FELLOW CITIZENS.
IT HAS BEEN A SHAMEFUL PART OF
OUR HISTORY.
THIS IS A COUNTRY FOUNDED ON
BASIC FREEDOMS, INCLUDING
FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
WE DO NOT HAVE RELIGIOUS TESTS
HERE.
OUR FOUNDERS, OUR CONSTITUTION,
OUR BILL OF RIGHTS ARE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT.
IF WE EVER ABANDON THOSE VALUES,
WE WOULD NOT ONLY MAKE IT A LOT
EASIER TO RADICALIZE PEOPLE HERE
AND AROUND THE WORLD, BUT WE
WOULD HAVE THE TRADE THE VERY
THINGS WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT,
THE PLURALISM AND OPENNESS, RULE
OF LAW, CIVIL LIBERTIES, THE
VERY THINGS THAT MAKE THIS
COUNTRY GREAT AND MAKE US
EXCEPTIONAL.
THEN, THE TERRORIST WOULD HAVE
WON.
I WILL NOT LET THAT HAPPEN.
TWO WEEKS AGO, I WAS AT THE
COMMENCEMENT CEREMONY AT THE AIR
FORCE ACADEMY.
IT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE
INSPIRING TO SEE THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE STEPPING UP, DEDICATED TO
SERVE AND PROTECT THIS COUNTRY.
PART OF WHAT WAS INSPIRING WAS
THE INCREDIBLE DIVERSITY OF
THESE CADETS.
WE SAW CADETS APPLAUDING
CLASSMATES WHO ARE OPENLY GAY.
CLASSMATES WHO WERE IMMIGRANTS
AND LOVED THIS COUNTRY SO MUCH
THEY DECIDED THEY WANTED TO BE
PART OF OUR ARMED FORCES.
WE SAW CADETS AND FAMILIES OF
ALL RELIGIONS APPLIED CADETS WHO
ARE PROUD PATRIOTIC MUSLIM
AMERICANS, SERVING THEIR COUNTRY
IN UNIFORM, READY TO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO PROTECT YOU
AND ME.
WE SAW MILL CADETS APPLAUDING
FEMALE CLASSMATES WHO CAN NOW
SERVE IN COMBAT POSITIONS.
THAT IS THE AMERICAN MILITARY.
THAT IS AMERICA.
ONE NATION.
THOSE ARE THE VALUES THAT ISIL
IS TRYING TO DESTROY.
WE SHOULD NOT HELP THEM DO IT.
I DIVERSITY AND RESPECT -- OUR
DIVERSITY AND RESPECT FOR ONE
ANOTHER, DRAWING ON THE TALENTS
OF EVERYBODY IN THIS COUNTRY,
MAKING SURE THAT WE TREAT
EVERYBODY FAIRLY, THAT WE ARE
NOT JUDGING PEOPLE ON THE BASIS
OF WHAT FAITH THEY ARE, OR RACE,
OR ETHNICITY, OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES THIS COUNTRY
GREAT.
THAT IS THE SPIRIT WE SEE IN
ORLANDO, THE UNITY AND RESOLVE
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO DEFEAT
ISIL.
THAT IS WHAT WILL PRESERVE OUR
VALUES AND IDEALS THAT DEFINE US
AS AMERICANS.
THAT IS HOW WE ARE GOING TO
DEFEND THIS NATION AND HOW WE
WILL DEFEND HER WAY OF LIFE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MARK C.: LIVE ON BLOOMBERG
TELEVISION, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FROM THE U.S.
TREASURY DEPARTMENT IN
WASHINGTON.
THE PRESIDENT MAKING REMARKS,
FOLLOWING A MEETINGMARK C.: WITE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL,
DESCRIBING THE FIGHT AGAINST THE
ISLAMIC STATE, THE MASSACRE THIS
WEEKEND IN ORLANDO, FLORIDA, AND
GIVING HARSH CRITICISM TO THE
PRESUMPTIVE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE,
DONALD TRUMP.
I AM JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT TOUCHING ON A
NUMBER OF POINTS.
ANGELA: THE INTENT OF THE
MEETING INITIALLY WAS TO TALK TO
HIS TOP ADVISERS ABOUT THE
ISLAMIC STATE.
THE
NATIONAL SECURITYHE DID THAT.
THE MESSAGE IS THE SAME AS WHAT
WE HEARD FROM THE PRESIDENT TWO
MONTHS AGO WHEN HE LAST
SPOKE ON THIS TOPIC.
HE SAYS THAT THEY'RE MAKING
PROGRESS ON THIS, BUT IT IS AN
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE LONE WOLF
PEOPLE LIKE THE SHOOTER IN
FLORIDA THIS PAST WEEKEND.
THE PRESIDENT ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
IT IS A DIFFICULT TASK AHEAD OF
THEM.
MARK C.: THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN
CAME UP.
HE WAS JOINED BY SOME OF